those they're aware of all the variables
I'm a thinker I think Alice yes analyzed
I think a lot I mean it's good because
it's prepared you very well and it's
made you this incredible martial artist
but it's also it creates a lot of
anxiety because you're aware of all the
possibilities whereas a person who
doesn't think that much just I'm just
gonna go in there [ __ ] people up like
that person might have an easier path to
fight but they might also have a shorter
limited potential absolutely because
they're not aware of all the
possibilities and they're not aware of
all their flaws and all not aware of all
their strengths and weaknesses they just
know what they've done that's worked and
they just keep doing that and instead of
developing this incredibly well-rounded
game they have a very very limited game
but that limited game works on some
people I agree it's it's it's this part
that the sport in general it's kind it's
kind of not fair when you look at it
likely look like Demetrius Johnson's
probably right now the best ever the
best ever yeah I agree like man when I
talk about confidence and skills man
what is the better guide in this what
better guide in this Dominick Cruz
freaking amazing man TJ Dillashaw that's
one fight look I don't watch every
fighter game
I don't watch every fight because I'm
not a fan of every fighter but if
there's a fight that I will pay my own
ticket to sit in front and fly myself is
Dominick Demetrius Johnson against TJ
Dillashaw absolutely a man has to be
done I don't there is always things in
factor that we don't know why it doesn't
happen maybe we don't know everything
unfortunately and yeah like like back in
the day me and understand still voice a
lot after why it didn't happen is there
stuff that people don't know that led
that back in the day I thought and then
I wanted to take care and then happen
but there's this fight man is just crazy
man sometimes sudden the sport light
like you have fight like Mayweather
Mayweather Pacquiao and it did not
happen it sucked but it is what it is
you know I think that
Demetrius wants TJ Dillashaw to fight
once
25 pounds show that he can make the
weight especially when he's dealing with
this incredibly long win streak he's
defended his title more than any other
champion ever so he doesn't want someone
to come along and break his win streak
that doesn't even make it way they did
this as a I have thought about this
because I've been in a similar situation
yeah this is a way to take care of this
with the lawyers you brighten the
contract that if you don't make weight
is no fight and the purse you make the
guy paying you a purse not that you see
Dillashaw would take difference give the
purse you know what I mean yeah no I do
but no need to be game enough to do it
it's a freakin risk yeah yeah but I
think Demetrius is worried that the UFC
will pressure him into fighting TJ even
if TJ doesn't make the way so we have TJ
mess for sure for sure it will make him
look bad in terms of with the fan base
and his brand mhm
I agree however we can make it through
the lawyer to the if it's that much
weight difference there is no fight
right you know there's always fights man
Joe there's something I've learned fight
can be negotiate the way you want I can
negotiate a fight like depending the the
laws okay I want you to wear pink
speedos when I fight you it's in that
contract you have to wear a spring
speedo I want you to wear this or any
like a fifth-round or if it's everything
could be done if it's written and and
and by the law
agreed yeah it could be worked out
I don't think too much they will be
worked out this guys let's do it man
let's go well I think right now the
rematch is set for Cody Garr Brandt
versus TJ Dillashaw and Mighty Mouse
just went through shoulder surgery yeah
he's rehabilitating his shoulder that's
gonna take quite a while and that
there's dammit the minute Cruz two in
the mix man it's amazing yeah he's
amazing I like to watch him a lot yeah
there's a lot of talent there's a lot of
talent UFC right now the smaller guy are
so much better than the bigger guy now
I'm telling you the truth like like if I
would have the same size as this guy a
minute I don't want to fight this guy
man I would they would beat the [ __ ] out
of me like no man they don't have
gravity [ __ ] with them I agree they
know that the gravity they not have that
size
but they're so good my so good to watch
them I'm learning I'm learning a lot I
watch a lot more of these guys and then
in terms of for learning yeah men how
beautiful was that Ambar that Demetrius
Johnson [ __ ] many slammed well I slam to
the armbar in the air and he said now I
practice at that woman trader you learn
I learned from these guy man I learned
from a lot of these guys yeah did you
switch man every time he's changed then
the cruise man is footwork man it's been
trained with Duane Ludwig long time ago
yes I have a spur we train when I was in
Denver helping Nathan Marquardt for a
fight I spy man it was crazy spar with
Dwayne Nate shank a twin - oh my god
shank oh yeah that was that smart but I
did yeah [ __ ] that yeah that wasn't that
smart I was back in the day maybe I
should have been smarter by and this is
because your head thanks God I didn't
get hurt but oh my god it was yeah I'm
up I remember in a training EEE
he wasn't grounded pounder with another
guy that is like a light everybody knock
him out yeah he's a big monster but that
was stupid on my part when I when you're
young you do stupid [ __ ] I should not
have done it yeah [ __ ] that huh where do
you weigh back then it weighs a mere or
am I the same a car whinnies maybe like
20 yeah he's a big guy [ __ ] huge yeah
I know it that was stupid but I did it
and then you know you move man you got a
[ __ ] move
yeah man hit ya hit and run man run
don't try to stand in the pocket with
this guy and if you go for it take that
you you go in and out and then quit man
holy [ __ ] yeah your timing has to be
perfect yeah [ __ ] that the only one
round yeah one round yeah yeah we went
with everybody you know there's this
thing